good luck thanks
she doesn't need luck she's emma
radekanu
the queen of the us open paired for one
match only with the future queen of
england
it was a homecoming for all four british
winners in new york but this 18 year old
is the standout star
this level of attention will now be the
norm for emma radicano and quite often
the glare can be too much but with it
comes huge opportunities
her victory in new york brought instant
fame and she's just signed a big deal to
promote jewelry there is a whirlwind
around her but she is just focused on
enjoying the game
did you know the duchess had such a good
forehand
before i didn't but once we got out
there i mean duchess was hitting the
ball extremely well and after we warmed
up she was going straight for it
i still think i'm early in my
development physically so i don't think
i can be playing week in week out as
some other players might so i'm going to
work on developing physically and but
yeah it's exciting times i can compete
with the best regularly now
her determination to win more titles is
clear she's now dropped one of her
coaches andrew richardson who was part
of the new york team
winners don't stand still and she now
wants someone with more elite level
experience
capitalizing on her success means this
game reaching youngsters right around
the uk
and making sure they can play on good
accessible tennis courts
when i got into wheelchair tennis i
wasn't playing an event at a venue like
this so um
yeah there's still lots to be done and
i'm come from norfolk and there's a lot
of courts there that can that can be
revamped
britain's new number one certainly isn't
getting carried away
a u.s open victory was very special but
come the australian open in january
she'll be the one to beat
tom parmenter sky news at the national
tennis centre